at Christmas time nothing screams
I've got my life together
quite like the smell of freshly baked
gingerbread cookies
and you and I both know that I'm barely
hanging on by a thread
but the people that are about to arrive at my house
must never find out
so instead today
we're gonna work a little bit of Christmas
magic with the Circa holiday range
and I fell in love with this range last Christmas
they've got three beautiful scents to choose from
and the obvious choice for today is the gingerbread cookies
it's a warm and inviting scent of ginger
cosy cinnamon and a sweet mix of brown sugar and vanilla
and hopefully it convinces everyone
that I totally just made this gingerbread
house from scratch
top it with icing sugar to hide any sins
and if anyone asks I was definitely going for rustic ok
is it pretty?
debateable
but is it edible?
also debateable
but does my house smell like Martha Stewart's kitchen
on Christmas morning?
pretty sure it does
before Snoop gets there at least
I added some Circa minis
which would make super cute festive favours
and now I cosplay
as somebody who definitely has time to
make gingerbread houses from scratch